Mr secretary how many children have been
sold into sex slavery under your
Administration Senator we are taking it
to the cartel how many children have
been sold into sex slavery do you know
how many children I mean how many were
sold under Trump the idea that because
the number isn't zero under any
Administration that it's this particular
individual's fault is absurd told the
sex slavery to an unprecedented degree
Mr secretary I want to say to you right
now your behavior is disgraceful and the
deaths the children assaulted the
children raped they are at your feet and
what about all of the ones under Trump
given that this is a global issue it's
not about minimizing it's well it's very
capricious and arbitrary for Ted Cruz to
be indignant when Biden is president but
to never have said anything about the
exact same thing under Trump